oh my god Brandon's my best friend
yes Brandon's all Brandon's they're like
best friends
yeah they're super sweet people brian is
a trustworthy name brian is a hot name
Brian's like your friend too nick is
totally a friend's name yeah just like
Nick is Nick and danik is very
unoffensive thanks are a good name yeah
if your name's Nick like you're fine
everyone's gonna like you
I feel like Jax for some reason I get a
vibe that we're gonna like swindle you
they're the ones that are gonna cheat on
you
red-flag named TJ RJ Josh is a red flag
like RJ TJ PJ no Jacob Zachary Jacob
stupid don't do this with Jacob again
yeah anybody who goes by their last name
that's my favorite David David's a
powerful man named like Michael classic
names
yeah William oh yeah especially if they
do the whole name I feel like Liam's our
business guy yeah I see em suited up did
you have a friend a girlfriend that
you're concerned about and she tells you
she's starting to date a William it's
common it's connected okay okay the name
that I am most likely to be like a guy
who's kind of grosses Adam oh I love the
name Adam atoms are like I finger Bank
someone in the bathroom I didn't wash my
hands Bob I also could never say Bob and
be serious about it like I could never
be night with some gonna be like come on
Bob Steve Oh something nerd it's tough
to be a Steve Frank I think Frank is not
a good looking or the thing the name
Frank is kind of like whatever is but
that I happen to know some like really
hot Franks do I I would love to say that
I ended up with a Dylan thing I'd love
to date a Brandon of course you would
I've always wanted to dated James
Ethan Oh surfer boy totally then you
like Ethan I like Ethan's are confident
just smoking hot has this amazing like
sense of humor I love Jake Jake is my
favorite male name Jake is rugged yeah
Jake is like the hearthrob very fit very
cool got the nicest five o'clock shadow
you've ever seen I think Parker is a hot
name Parker is suicide I've even met a
Parker no maybe that's why it's a I
don't know
you